[Musique]
Miss autisme
regretter de Ne pouvoir
venir
duneur
Madame m'stis regrette de Ne pouvoir
venir
Le dîner
mais ici Au bois elle est
allée dans l'allée des
amoureux s'est
égaré
Madame Miss Miss autisme
regretter de Ne pouvoir
venir
[Musique]
duner quand elle
comprit c'est quoi Bel amour
était
ailette
Madame elle a couru vers
l'homme qui avait
scandaleux
trahi de Sa robe fr
velours
chinois sorti Tun
brome
et
toi sans
hésiter
Madame mes autistes
Je regrette
pouvoir
venir
duneur
la faute
vin Forcer la Prison
et le
saisit
Madame la
amène jusqu'au vieux tyol oou on
la
bandi
plus juste
trp avant
passer elle relève sa Jolie tte pour
murmureur
Madame Miss autisme
Je regrette de ne pas pouvoir venir
[Musique]
Le dîner